being the first company to put fans
inside their phone Nubia is bringing the
big guns out with the grid Magic 8 Pro
this is probably the ultimate gaming
phone and probably the best one I've had
my hands on in a very long time this is
the red Magic 8 Pro in its mad version
there's also a void version that
features a transparent backing that
looks pretty sweet wish we had that on
hand but we have the other sexy AF
offering in matte black red magic balls
that this is the first OLED full screen
within the industry and by that I mean
there isn't a visible notch or a
front-facing cam because it's actually
underneath the screen it is a mighty
fine looking phone off the bat with its
Aviation aluminum frame so let's get the
bases out of the way first the red Magic
8 Pro uses a Qualcomm Snapdragon 8 Gen 2
plus a dedicated gaming chip called the
red core 2. basically that's a lot of
power it has a 6 000 milliamp hour dual
cell battery or basically two 3 000
million Power Batteries in the back and
it has super fast charging at 65 Watts
storage depends on the design you get
the mat like the one we have down here
has 12 gigs of RAM and 256 gigs of
storage whilst the void version has 16
gigs of RAM and 512 gigs of storage both
versions come with a pair of 520 Hertz
dual shoulder triggers and both ones run
the ice level multi-dimensional cooling
system and a whole bunch of other stuff
before anything else I really want to
point out this phone's shoulder triggers
most gaming phones already have triggers
but red magic is coming in with ultra
fast Tippy Taps and full on
customization in ways that will surprise
you other players will not see coming
these things have served me extremely
well when I'm playing card and pubg but
we'll get into that later on the map add
version has a certain set of class to it
I'm pretty sure the void looks just as
cool and Sleek IRL but the matte feel
and look of the phone pad with its
subtle flavor text and including with
Magic's new logo so good looking it's
handsome it's not gimmicky at all you
probably don't need a case for this
because it isn't a super smudge magnet
and I really wouldn't want to cover up
the design at the back because why would
you
also there's an input rifle on the phone
if you're into that
I really just wonder how gaming phone
companies come up with this stuff well
I'm going back but to be fair shark
channel on my black shark fight for a
week so every morning so so gamingwise
the Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 coupled with the
ice11 cooling system the 520hz Dual
shoulder triggers and 6 000 million
power battery combined with this
beautiful display makes it more than 35
for gaming there's also the red Core 2
which is a secondary chip made to
process everything else like audio
haptic feedback and RGB lighting which
is available at the back of the phone it
helps you gain better so that the
Snapdragon can focus on performance
through our gaming tests and benchmarks
it can pretty much handle anything
that's thrown at it without breaking a
sweat whether it's Genji an impact or
Apex Legends you'll get beautiful
graphics and a smooth performance
without the heat thanks to the
improvements red magic has made to its
heat dissipation so in addition to its
fans that run at 20 000 RPM they also
put in a layer of graphene under the
screen with a large 3D Vapor cooling
plate and like eight other layers
that'll keep your phone cool throughout
your day and your gameplay so if you you
don't need to worry about it overeating
or or anything this this thing oh
now if you want to get into gaming real
quick just shift this red button down
here to the side and it'll send you
straight to the red Magic game Space
where you can manage your games plugins
which almost feel like cheating and
screencasting options don't forget the
all the settings you can change and boy
there are a lot I'm gonna be honest and
say there is a steep learning curve
about this phone's game settings alone
in all the fully utilize all of its
features but you can also just skip past
all of that concern yourself with only
the fan modes performance and GPU mode
and color settings for the various games
types like racing and Shooters you will
still be able to enjoy playing games
right out of the box without having much
to set up and speaking of setting things
up the triggers are pretty easy to set
up
but yes they are just swipe left or
right on these gray bars click this and
just place the positions of the triggers
here onto the side and the fire buttons
and you can program the triggers to long
press double tap turning any gun to
firing bursts only so red magic has an
extensive list of whatever type of
button click they would think you need
in whatever situations you would find
yourself in games or whatever play
Styles you have so wow like heads often
after that there are a ton of options
here to play the games you do the way
you want to and don't even get me
started on the plugins because you can
set the magnifying glass in the middle
of the screen so you never need the
scope in game or invert the colors for
predator-esque view to better spot your
enemies without the sound unfortunately
I don't really use these plugins because
I am a very fair kind of player I like
to think of pretty decent in most games
but they are always there for your
proposal and use also do take note that
not every plugin will be available for
every game and if you want to know what
games are compatible with which plugins
they are in the description for each
plugin some of the titles like pubg are
supposed to have certain plugins like
hunt mode investigate mode and double
tap assist which says it's meant for
fps's but it doesn't turn up on the menu
for pubg and say called mobile
respectively hopefully Nubia updates it
at some point so besides being impressed
with the options they have the triggers
themselves are extremely responsive and
I haven't found myself struggling with
firing or aiming down sights in any way
and I have to say the inclusion of
triggers in any form is always an added
and welcome Advantage similar to the Rog
and blackshock phones though I prefer
the blackshox tactile triggers but
that's a that's a me thing besides that
you can also manage and create notes
especially for games like gen chin and
Diablo you need to take note of certain
things the game Space feels like a true
extension of the experience of having
the red Magic 8 Pro and I don't find it
a hassle to use unlike other similar
game menus hubs and speaking of the game
Space why not shoot for the stars with
your productivity in style with the Asus
Zenbook 14x All That Space Edition
this video is brought to you by Asus
check out the Asus Zenbook 14x OLED
Space Edition commemorating the 25th
anniversary of the first Asus laptop
sent into space Not only does it offer a
space exclusive design but it's even
worthy of going where no man has gone
before with its space gray durability it
even comes with a 3.5 inch OLED
companion Zen Vision display and you
will have a ball of a time taking
interviews with a 16 by 10 4K OLED Nano
Edge Pantone validated 14 inch display
performance so far with gaming has been
pretty damn solid and that's still an
understatement since I had quite a bit
of time with it in our game test video
you can check out like right here
somewhere on there please check it out I
got some good kills I was playing
genshin and then pubg and then Apex and
then caught m one after another back to
back and the temperatures were still a
solid 33 years to 38 at Max the battery
went down from like 100 to as little as
what 70 percentage after full games
we're talking like 20 and 30 minute
games back to back and the fans and the
ice 11 heat management system didn't
break a sweat with how efficient it is
but I really believe the games ran
smoothly in the upper to the recall 2
which again takes away all the
processing for audio haptic feedback and
RGB lighting basically anything else
that this stamp Dragon 8 Gen 2 doesn't
need to be concerned about so that it
can focus on getting the best
performance for your games and all I can
say is damn on top of all that we find
some benchmarks with geekbench and 3D
Mark and here are the results offset
benchmarks alright with the benchmark
scores in it's one three nine six for
the single core and five two one zero
for the multi-core let's check how it
fares against other phones single core
wise it's stacked up at 1396 compared to
a lot of all the phones like the S31
plus 5G which is at 906 or even the
ultra 909 even the xiaomi Poco F3 set
932 so this thing is doing pretty well
in terms of single call but when you go
to Monte car it's a five to one zero and
it completely obliterates all the
competition here so it's about 30-ish
not too bad just like we've seen with
the games
let's check the back 29ish
not too bad I mean geekbench is pretty
light when it comes to processes so
let's put it through 3D Market see what
happens we're on the 10th Loop of the 3D
Mark test so you can hear the fence
revving
so that's the fans revving up and let's
do a quick temperature check on the
front of the screen
it's heating up pretty oh 44. that's the
highest I've Seen It Go
wow
oh my God it's hot okay let's check the
back
oh it's about the same as the front Okay
so let's check back in a bit and see how
it fares on the 20th Loop
and we just got done with the wildlife
extreme stress test and this thing is
still working out you can just hear the
fans
it's still working on clearing the heat
out but let's see what the scores are
like but oh my oh that is hot
4142 that is extremely hot
to the touch even
this thing's hot
39 37 34 wow the temperature's actually
going down at the back I wonder if it's
changed on the front oh yeah
everything's going down that's pretty
quick
wow
okay all right so based on the wallet
extreme stress test we have a best Loop
score of three seven two zero any lowest
Loop score of three six four five and
that's pretty impressive let's see
whether
oh interesting reverse performance
monitoring it's battery went down from
100 to 88 temperature wise went to 30
degrees Celsius to 48 degrees Celsius
which is a lot more than the games we
played which usually hover about like 30
to about 35 maybe at Max 38 but never 48
but then again it's an extreme stress
test and frame rate runs from 17 FPS to
27 FPS so pretty damn impressive so far
so this phone has to cover performance
wise for days performance for days
performance for days I get the downside
of owning this phone is that its camera
is just
well it's there if you want to use it
it's not the best on the 0.5 times and
anything above one honestly
I think videos on this thing
stabilization is pretty much
non-existent I mean it's meant to be a
gaming phone first and everything else
second so don't expect Stellar pictures
and videos but it does get the job done
if you're on a stickler for image and
video quality like Bobby Zacky and IR
then it shouldn't bother you so much all
in all gaming on this has been a dream I
genuinely enjoyed playing all my games
on the red Magic 8 Pro then there are
the plugins and the options to add notes
you can pull up in the game later on and
then there are a lot of options and the
red magic has really sat down and put a
lot of thought into that when it comes
to gaming on this phone saying this
phone is just solid for gaming is a
grievous understatement and if this is
the future red magic is bringing to the
table I am all for it if you have any
questions about this phone leave them in
the comment section down below and I'll
do my best to get to them make sure to
follow us on all of our socials right
here and if you want to see the gaming
test and how this thing fares in a real
world test just keep on watching but
don't forget to drop that like And
subscribe to us it goes a long way I'll
see you again soon before we get into
the gaming test let's just do a little
temperature check so on the front we
haven't really done much with this yet
so let's just see
26. the Fan's not on yet by the way
so here we go 26 degrees 26.5 around
here and at the back
25.6 25.9 nothing really hitting 30 so
we are good to go
all right with the game set let's just
get into it so before we get into the
game let's just set up the performance
monitor so either swipe left or right it
works either way
here we go info
so now here we get a sense of the FPS
and the timer play and also our
percentage and how much time we've
played on as well
so right now we're 100 battery and let's
just keep it in the corner down here
let's also set up the triggers
once we get in the game
we have download down here let's set up
the settings real quick
right so graphically we are on the
highest everywhere
hi hi hi
EST 65ps high oh we can go extreme
actually but now in this motion but I
don't want that Bloom's on because why
not ta is on 28 listen
and okay we're good we're set but before
that let's just go and walk around the
city real quick so with the triggers
there are a ton of options on what kind
of triggers you want so as you can see
this long press Rapid Fire for more the
FPS stuff and after that this press
Trigger or macros
which you can enable down here and on
top of that there's also the rapid fire
which you can increase or decrease the
click frequency so now that we're in the
city this is a beautiful screen it's
showing off everything beautifully there
hasn't been any frame rate drops it is
the red Magic Pro is handling this like
a beast and I just need to point out
that the front-facing camera is hidden
underneath the screen so you guys won't
have any notches breaking any sort of
immersion and let's just keep moving
through the city so with that let's just
get into a fight real quick
foreign
[Applause]
no
more
[Laughter]
let's check temperatures we're currently
at 92 battery with about 0.6 hours on
play of time
a blade Embraces its Duty yeah I'll do
pretty well I don't listen to the touch
it's quite it's not warm but it's not
cold either so it's kind of in the
middle
room temperature almost
towards the warmer side but I think that
it feels really good in hand let's just
check the back real quick
33 36 34. so yeah honestly there's
nothing to complain about this it's a
beast so far but let's get into the next
game
School UHD still not available Ultra HD
though yes frame rate Ultra because we
can afford it I kind of want to go for
more colorful one and just play through
a score of four times and DLC oh still
coming still not available let's go two
times instead
Shadows enabled brightness non-standard
screens area everything is set so let's
just
get into the game
[Applause]
he feels a bit very nice
yeah it's very responsive the triggers
[Applause]
can't see where these guys at oh I see
him now
[Applause]
there you go
he's down one more guy left
push it in
oh it is
there we go so let's check Final
temperatures before we get into the next
game
currently we're on FPS 83 left 2.5 hours
with half an hour into the match
[Applause]
35.3 nothing has changed so far that fan
is doing damn well for this
all right let's check the back
33 34. yeah this phone is amazing
all right so before the game let's check
out temperatures real quick
32-ish
yeah it has gone on quite a bit and we
and we just came off pubg by the way so
the fan and its ice 11 cooling system is
really doing
the job let's check the back
24-32
yeah these are really really healthy
numbers
[Music]
all right so let's check settings real
quick
so extreme HD for graphics quality ultra
high frame rate a depth smoothie is on
display FPS we don't need that since we
already have the red magic one already
fpv all set to what I like V6 on
everything on Advanced is turned on high
or turned on
oh okay but everything's rendering
pretty nicely except for that I think
it's a game really a phone issue
[Applause]
there you go you
finish up
very smooth
[Music]
0.4 hours on the clock 61 FPS 60 FPS
and there's obviously noises just here
the triggers feel great when I'm playing
with them again I'll not use any of the
plugins for this run through because I
like to play fair
and just like that we you kind of won
wow okay so so far our experience with
Apex has been pretty smooth no drastic
FPS jobs whatsoever the triggers feel
amazed the play and fire and aim with so
let's just do a final temperature check
before we move on to the next game
right at the other game right about like
what 0.4 hours we're down to 75 from the
original 80 percent
30-ish across the board wow it's not bad
actually that's really in line with
everything else and we've been playing
games back to back so after Apex we're
going to go into Call of Duty mobile the
Mage is looking really good right now
okay a little bit if you're gonna drop
for some reason let's just open this up
currently at 28 FPS but let's see where
we can change it up in the settings
according Graphics let's go very high
you can't
change it up and kind of go around the
highest
for Idol so it seems to do with other
phones
um you can only go with high for the max
if you want to go Ultra frame rate for
multiplayer
it will automatically bring you down to
low
so let's just go with Max frame rate and
very high so at least we got the highest
on both ends ish and then let's see
multiplayer there's a field and Deals In
Bloom and record let's put all that in
oh it's not that would be very smart
[Applause]
capture Charlie
so with the max done there hasn't been a
huge tip in the FPS it's still been at a
constant almost 58 inches 51 FPS and
you're only about 0.2 hours in
[Applause]
there we go
that's the way
[Applause]
for deployment
all right and that's the second match
let's check the temperatures real quick
before we hit the conclusions
[Applause]
okay
33 36 and 4 35 that's pretty good wow
okay let's just nice work these are my
thoughts I really enjoy playing with the
red Magic 8 Pro I kind of see red magic
put so much thought into creating this
phone whether it's the fans inside that
goes in Tangent with the ice 11 cooling
system the red car 2 chip that takes
away every other process to let the Mead
Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 focus on performance
or the amount of options plugins and
features game Space has this is a phone
that is going in the direction gaming
phones should be heading response times
on the screen and triggers are more than
there and the feeling of playing with it
in my hand is immaculate simply put I
enjoyed the heck out of playing with
this phone
foreign
[Music]